whether you love it hate it or never
thought about it chances are some nanny
wants to ban it presenting the nanny of
the month runners-up Fort Lee New Jersey
for banning texting while walking what
is hideously ugly gigantically dangerous
and outrageously expensive in Los
Angeles egged on by Julia Louie Dreyfus
for making the City of Angels the
nation's largest jurisdiction to
prohibit plastic bags but there can be
only one nanny of the month and this
time it's who else Big Apple busybody
Michael Bloomberg for banning large
sodas 16 ounces is the maximum that they
would be able to serve not content with
cracking down on salt trans fat smoking
even in private homes alcohol school
bake sales happy hour and donating food
to City homeless shelters method might
decided to cities anti soda ads just
weren't cutting it not even the
photoshopped ones that suggest soda
could literally cost you your leg we
have an obligation to warn you when
things aren't good for your health it's
clear there's no end point for the soda
jerk and the New York Times even invited
readers to suggest what he should ban
next so what'll it be Mike cheese on
pizza leaving the seat up wanted to
slather the city in Purell and mandate
daily exercises check back next month
for more examples of busybodies minded
your own business